- Bladesmiths, welcome to our
strength test, the bolt baton.
Now what I'm going to do
is take this well-used bat,
and I'm going to take
your friction folders.
And I'm going to baton
the back of your blades
at three different
points on those bolts.
Derek, you're up first.
You ready?
Uh, yeah, I guess.
Do what you do.
[music playing]
DEREK: J looks like an
evil villain ready to do
some serious destruction.
Come on, baby.
Hold together.
[music playing]
[shouts]
- [laughing]
- It didn't fly apart.
That's hard to watch.
[music playing]
All right, Derek,
first of all,
you did have a little
bit of edge damage here.
You got a couple
rolls here where I
can actually catch my nail on.
You do still have
tension, but the problem
is your blade did shift.
DEREK: OK.
And when I go to close it,
now it's catching on this side.
But your edge held
up fairly well.
Overall, good job.
Thank you.
Bob, you ready to play?
It's what I came for.
J: All right, let's do it.
[music playing]
BOB: My edge profile might
be just a little bit thin
for this test.
So I'm nervous as a long-tailed
cat in a room full of rockers.
You got this.
We'll see.
[music playing]
All right, Bob.
The big issue was--
Oh.
--there is no mechanical
connection back here.
There's no pins.
When I struck the spine, the
shock traveling down that blade
just blew that epoxy apart.
All right, John,
how you feeling?
Oh, just ready to
get it over with.
[music playing]
Mine has got to be the
thinnest blade there.
It's not meant to have this
type of abuse put on it.
[music playing]
Little blood this time.
All right, John, we've
got a few issues here.
You don't have
rolls on your edge.
You have pieces missing.
And though I like the
fact you used a steel pin,
it's very small
and it didn't hold,
just blew right out of place.
So now your blade just--
your pivot point
just didn't hold up.
[music playing]
To see and test the
edge of your folders,
I'm going to take your weapon
and slice across this ham.
Derek, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Let's talk about the edge.
It's razor sharp.
All right.
The way I was able to
cut through this ham,
it sliced easily and deep.
Your blade will cut.
All right.
All right, Bob,
it's your turn.
You ready?
If you're ready, I'm willing.
[music playing]
Very nice.
DOUG: All right, Bob.
We have an issue with your
handle here being loose.
But the good thing
about friction folders
is it is the hand that holds
it in place with the handle,
secure enough to where I'm
still able to test with it.
I like the way it
feels in the hand.
Your edge is sharp.
It slices easy.
It's light and fast,
and it will cut.
Thank you.
Good job.
All right, John, it's your turn.
You ready?
- Let's do it.
[music playing]
Nice.
Way to go.
Thank you.
Despite having chips on the
edge here, as you can see,
it cuts easily into the ham.
It's just this part
where you can't keep it
close without holding on to it.
It's lost its
friction in that part.
It will cut.
Thank you, sir.
Good job.
HOST: Bladesmiths, the judges'
deliberation is complete,
and it's time for one of you
smiths to leave the forge.
The bladesmith
leaving the forge is--
[music playing]
John, your blade did
not make the cut.
J. Neilson's going
to tell you why.
J: Now John, I
liked your concept,
but that small pin being
unsecured and popping loose,
it's no longer a
friction folder.
And because of that, you failed
to fulfill the requirements
of the challenge.
And that's why we're
sending you home.
Understood.